[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis ce qu'on surpris du déficit
d'image dont la jeunesse agenaise
s'entendre et aujourd'hui adolescents et
jeunes adultes souffrent auprès de
l'opinion publique
j'en veux pour preuve les commémorations
du 2 mai 68 dont on vient de parler et
on est évidemment dans une université
pour évoquer cet événement à l'occasion
de cette commémoration d'un cran du goût
d'un côté une survalorisation de
l'engagement politique idéologique de la
jeunesse d'alors
je laisse qui étaient investis motivés
prêts à changer la société et même le
monde et par contre coup on a entendu
beaucoup de critiques sur la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui qui serait elle
par contraste tout à fait dépolitiser
votants clune militants plus une
jeunesse qui seraient des intéressés et
détaché des enjeux de notre monde
contemporain et qui préféreraient
l'addiction aux écrans et la passion
immodérée pour les séries et autres
fictions d'imaginaire donc on voit bien
que dans le monde adulte
il y a une grande méfiance vis-à-vis de
la culture des jeunes un triple méfiance
je crois d'abord on dit considère que
c'est une culture populaire au mauvais
sens du terme un succès green souvent
avec suspect à lui un événement un objet
culturel est planétaire
plus on boxe de sa qualité deuxième
critique une culture qu'il serait une
culture du divertissement culture de
l'évasion donc la musique à merrill en
tête même immature c'est une façon
d'éviter de regarder les problèmes en
face
et enfin troisième critique l'a pas
grave je crois c'est une culture de
l'imaginaire
vous savez que dans la société française
une hêtraie de trois siècles de
cartésianisme on a toujours tendance à
valoriser la rationalité la
scientificité contre la créativité et
l'imagination
je pense personnellement au contraire
que la culture que ceux choisis
aujourd'hui la jeunesse les fictions
qu'elle consomme et la façon dont elle
les consomme est déjà une preuve de
profonds changements et je voudrais vous
en donner quelques exemples
je commence avec la dystopie pourquoi
les dix te plies parce que c'est le
genre préférentiel des ados et jeunes
adultes depuis une quinzaine d'années et
qu'on la trouve absolument partout
maintenant les romandes dans les séries
télé et film
et même dans les jeux vidéo en et
dystopie c'est d'abord le lieu de la
révolution de la révolte de la
transgression événement examen parfois
un baccalauréat par lequel la société
des adultes essaient d'imposer aux
jeunes nous place dans la société
il sera associé à cela une jeune
justement refuse une choisi de diverger
d'argent quelqu'un ne veut pas mettre
ses pieds dans une main ce qui aurait
été désigné en amont donc la liste open
elle est très philosophique c'est le
pari entre le déterminisme et que tout
est déjà joué à l'avancé
le pari de la détermination tout est à
faire
c'est à moins construire ma place par la
société déclare ma place deuxièmement
les dystopie c'est probablement de tous
les genres littéraires l'un des plus
politisés qui soit parce que c'est un
lieu où on peut mettre en scène
l'ensemble des questions de société les
sujets politiques
la dictature la surveillance le contrôle
idéologique la manipulation des faits
cnous c'est le lieu où peut parler d
évolution révolution scientifique
le clonage les manipulations génétiques
la procréation assistée
c'est le lieu où on peut parler de tout
les sujets écologiques environnementaux
qui touche aujourd'hui la planète avec
le gros boom les fictions post
apocalyptique dans lequel des jeunes et
héros doivent affronter précisément les
conséquences de ces questions et
écologique
donc au lieu loin d'être un dieu
immature la dystopie joint un
laboratoire d'idées un lieu où de
convoquer les vieux modèles les tester
en évaluer la pertinence on en contester
la légitimité et explorer de nouvelles
voies des formules alternatives
alors voilà justement dans les fictions
apocalyptique où les jeunes héros
doivent toujours une fois après avoir
affronté des conséquences
catastrophiques légué par les adultes
doivent apprendre une nouvelle relation
à l'environnement doivent se construire
une culture de la nature donc au fond on
voit que derrière la dystopie se cache
toujours un peu d'utopie le pari que peu
et on boit renverser le lire pour y
mettre un peu de meilleur
c'est ce qui m'amène à penser que même
la fantasy est je crois un lieu de
changement savez qu'il est pour les
adultes la fantasy est souvent très
suspecte on considère que c'est un lieu
de d'évasion et même de régression ces
lieux on revient au sujet de l'enfance
les rois et les princesses des magiciens
et les dragons donc le lieu où on évite
au fond une position d'adultes qui
serait une position responsable et qui
consiste à regarder le réel dans les
yeux mais moi je pense que la fantasy il
doit être pris au sens symbolique la
baguette magique de harry potter c'est
une métaphore c'est une métaphore des
pouvoir de l'imagination et si les
jeunes générations choisi d'élire harry
potter et d'antennes le phénomène
planétaire
l'oeuvre qui dans l'histoire de
l'humanité il n'est jamais eu autant de
lecteurs la seule oeuvre dans les seuls
domaines c'est parce qu'elle fait passer
un message nous monde des adultes
le choix d' harry potter c'est de dire
laisser non réenchanter le monde
laissez nous met du merveilleux dans une
réalité qui en est privée laissez nous
mettre un peu de lumière un peu de magie
un peu de rêve dans un quotidien qui est
bien souvent trop terme est sombre et
désespéré on ne change pas le monde
uniquement avec du pragmatisme de la
rationalité de la scientificité on
change aussi avec la créativité de
l'innovation et d'imaginaire donc je
crois qu'en faisant le choix de toutes
ces fictions ces mêmes fiction qui sont
souvent contesté voire méprisé par les
prêteurs éducatifs et culturels
les jeunes générations sont déjà en
train d'ébranler notre société
je pense que nous sommes en train
d'assister un profond changement de
paradigme en pendant 2000 ans la société
occidentale s'est construite sur un
modèle de transcription verticale les
adultes les aînés transmettent aux
jeunes une vision du monde des valeurs
des idéologies des choix de société et
des choix culturels effectivement jusque
dans les années 2000 quand on demandait
aux jeunes leur choix culturels y
donnait la littérature patrimoniale
réaliste bref le choix des adultes or
depuis 18 ans et pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de la société
occidentale les jeunes ont choisi de
s'affranchir de ce modèle de
transcription verticale ou de lui
substituer un modèle de transmission
horizontale le partage entre les pères
les changes via les forums les blogs les
réseaux sociaux donc on voit bien que
c'est un changement culturel profond on
passe une vision de la culture légitime
transcrites prescrite à une vision de la
culture partagée qu on scrute collective
où passent d'une vision de la culture
qui était très individuel très prisé à
une vision qui est partagé c'est pour
phénomène d'époque birth par exemple ou
veut on a besoin d'échanger et donc de
construire ensemble sa culture et enfin
c'est une culture qui n'est plus passive
mais il culture active la bulle puis il
a souvent tendance est dans une posture
le jeu lui n'hésite pas à participer
alarmant la retravailler à la règle pour
tous un lieu de créativité que mon
cochon et la façon dont les jeunes c'est
une culture qui refuse d'élitisme lit ou
très bon courage moral
la bourse de paris
continuer de regarder durant continué de
jouer à assassin's creed presse
continuent de diverger
parce que c'est en divergeant changement
et c'est en divergence des gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]